Esta es la vista desde el municipio
colombiano de erveo ubicado muy cerca
del volcán nevado del Ruiz que se
encuentra en alerta naranja los vecinos
sienten las consecuencias que se siente
a veces por ahí así algo de ceniza
Sí yo no se acuesta como nervioso
sienten miedo y piden ayuda yo siento
que en estos momentos nosotros estamos
en una zona de riesgo y necesitamos
mucha colaboración de del gobierno
departamental porque tenemos unas vías
de acceso muy malas para en caso de una
evacuación desde la alcaldía de erveo
aseguran que están siguiendo todos los
protocolos de prevención
prima acatado todos los boletines que
que nos han enviado y hemos hecho Pues
todos los protocolos necesarios para el
tema de evacuaciones de albergue de
puntos de encuentro este miércoles el
presidente Gustavo Petro ordenó acelerar
la evacuación de 2500 familias que se
encuentran en zona de riesgo Mientras
tanto el servicio geológico colombiano
mantiene la alerta naranja y la unidad
nacional para la gestión del riesgo de
desastres hizo una actualización
nos preocupa es que en este caso los
sismos cada vez se acercan más al cráter
Y esa según los vulcanólogos no es que
sea la mejor de las señales de hecho
este miércoles hubo un sismo de magnitud
de 3,9 El mayor desde 1985 cuando se
produjo la erupción más mortal del
volcán nevado del Ruiz que dejó más de
23.000 personas muertas